movement this episode of congratulations
is brought to you by movement look we
get it holiday shopping can be tough but
thanks to movement all that gift-giving
anxiety can disappear with the press of
a button these watches make the perfect
purchase for just about anyone in your
life guy or girl and they started only
95 dollars we'll talk about movement
later on in the show 15% off today with
free shipping and free returns by going
to nvm t.com slash Congrats this episode
is also brought to you by blue apron now
when you cook with blue apron you're not
just having burgers for dinner you're
making short rib burgers with a hoppy
cheddar sauce on a pretzel bun yummy
that sounds amazing you're prepping
seared steaks and thyme pan sauce with
mashed potatoes green beans and crispy
shallots in under 45 minutes and you
don't have to make a trip to the grocery
store blue apron is treating
congratulations listeners to their first
dinner a $30 value if you visit blue
apron home slash Congrats so check out
this week's menu and get your $30 off
today at blue apron calm slash Congrats
the cash app it seems the babies on this
show are switching to the cash episode
number 1 finance app in the App Store
and they've introduced the cash card a
new black debit card that you can design
yourself via the app it's very cool and
keep the you keep the cash
you use the cash that you keep in the
app anywhere you want it's best way to
pay people back download the free cash
app for iOS or Android now
[Music]
what's up are you guys doing babies
it's the 43rd episode I never know what
number it is on the episode but I know
it's number 43 right now and I am doing
a little bit too much cheese Ellen there
was a sports announcer once my brother
and I always make fun of it but he was
like I think it was a mood Chris Berman
or something I don't know but he was
talking about a baseball player and he
was like and he was doing the highlights
I don't know what the guy was doing he
was doing something cool and the and
every time I cut back to the baseball
player doing the cool thing the baseball
the announcer was like and doing a
little bit too much chiseling and it was
so ridiculous that like this old white
shark in baseball announcer would do
that [ __ ] and doing a little bit too
much chiselin like some white dude I saw
this funny the funniest [ __ ] thing on
the video podcast before we get started
I got a I got to share this with you
the beguine oh we put the video up what
did he put I think it was on the clip
was it on the clip yeah this is on the
laundry clip this comment dude killed me
he writes oh here we go
here this guy writes the the word is
memorable why does he add an S in the
beginning okay you know because I said
some Emeril in it and somebody wrote be
a baby to his comment and then he wrote
I'm 27 and then he wrote and then it's
like I wrote it's a Chris D'Elia thing
and babies are like his cult and he
writes so is there like an admission
form or something how do I pledge my
allegiance and the guy writes just don't
be a CUDA maybe laugh like this
think of this guy being like I don't
understand what the [ __ ] is going on and
then this guy's just keeps using the
language but yes so I was in Ohio this
past weekend I was in Columbus Ohio they
said it was gonna be freezin wasn't
really that freezin uh weather men don't
know what the [ __ ] they're doing I know
they talk about how weather can you know
they can predict it because it's coming
in from different areas but they don't
know the wind is the wind do you know
what I'm saying
they don't [ __ ] know the wind is the
wind and the wind picks up and goes
wherever the [ __ ] at once you know why
it's the wind and you're just a person
trying to predict where the wind is
going you're trying to predict where the
wind is going these weathermen how often
are they right I wonder how often
weather men are actually right because
maybe it's like 80% but maybe it's like
50 if it's 50 I'll just guess you know
if it's cloudy it might rain there I'm a
weatherman I'm a weatherman Jewish a
Jewish guy hey YUM I'm Bill weathermen
I'm Sid weathermen Sid the names SID
that's not a good name sounds awful but
yeah I had a good time in Columbus the
all the shows were sold out six shows a
lot of babies came um and and it was
very very fun to perform for them III
think I performed in Columbus Ohio when
I was opening up for Jo koy so I was
only featuring and then I did Columbus
Ohio I did a theater they are like two
years ago but then I wanted to do more
shows so I didn't admit the funny bone
this this past weekend and yeah it was
it was a good you know here lying first
of all when I was on the plane on the
way there the the stewardess was like
kept on coming by and saying for my
drink
do you need a skirt which is a napkin
but she kept on saying like and let me
get your skirt and like I don't know
what it is about [ __ ] like that that
just grinds my [ __ ] gears and it's
always grinding my gears to say to call
something a cute word it's always
grinding I remember being young as [ __ ]
and hearing somebody say take it sleazy
instead of take it easy and just be in
like a six year old thinking for the
first time [ __ ] I don't know
what the [ __ ] it is about that but like
say napkin first of all maybe skirt is
another word for like a cloth coaster
however it's not a coaster first of all
first of all don't call it that way even
if it's a coaster just a coaster it was
literally a napkin that had like
American Airlines on it it was a [ __ ]
napkin also it there's nothing worse
than an airplane napkin it might as well
be [ __ ] sandpaper when you got to
blow your nose and you use that just
pretty much shred your nose up just
pretty much put your nose on some
asphalt and rub your face around that's
what it is and she kept calling it skirt
and it bothered me the whole way there
now here's the other thing dude I want
to know us this is a survey I want to
know and from all the [ __ ] listeners
out there the babies and non babies I
just want to know if you're catching
this [ __ ] is everybody's nose just
always dry the inside of the [ __ ]
nose one fire is your [ __ ] nose dry
right now no okay
so never dry okay my nose is always dry
it's just always dry it's always [ __ ]
dry always up in the [ __ ] nasal [ __ ]
always dry I wake up feels like they're
shooting a movie up there okay it's all
crowded it's annoying
I got to [ __ ] blow my nose
my brain comes out and I take a shower
helps barely my mom would always be like
it's just it used the steam get in the
shower get the steam going you know
didn't help what they call it a witch's
it's a witch's tale get some steam in
the [ __ ] nose does that help or does
it just make it more damp then when it's
not damp anymore stri as hell so my nose
has just always dry and it's always
gonna be dry winter summer spring fall
if they make a new season it'll be dry
then - why I want to know why sometimes
I drink more water than a [ __ ]
Arrowhead dispenser I drink so much
water sometimes in a matter of fact
that's all I drink all I drink is water
and coffee and I know Coffee dehydrates
you but water replenishes you okay
so I drink so much water why is my nose
so dry what do I need to do to get my
nose not dry the [ __ ] do I need to do do
I need to to jam vicks vapor rub up
there or not vapor rub but the [ __ ]
Vaseline I mean nasal spray does not
work and I know everybody right now is
thinking well the nasal spray there's
there's this one nasal spray
no don't care don't like that guy when
people are like oh I gotta use this kind
though Oh see you're using the wrong
kind say yeah I'm not using the wrong
kind just what did [ __ ] this is
always dry it's dry up there right now
they're shooting [ __ ] Ragnarok for up
there um yeah it sucks and sometimes
then it's just dry on the bottom of it -
and I look like Tom Hanks in
Philadelphia at the end and I'm just
like dude I don't have [ __ ] HIV I'm
just it's my nose is always dry I drink
so much water I workout hard sweat it
all out
drink it up I'm drinking water I do them
all in thing I do more than work out
really hard at the gym is drink more
water
I have my gym this guy stopped me he was
like hey man cuz that was last episode I
was talking about the guy with in with
the [ __ ] shoe string in between his
two nipples when he worked out and he
was like hey man is that the guy and I
was like ah [ __ ] he was listening to my
podcast and he pointed to the guy who
actually I was talking about it was
funny it's nice to see babies at the gym
um shout out to that guy for making my
gym experience so yeah it sucks dude my
nose is always dry what do i do what do
I do in the this oh man you know what's
actually up bumming me out is the the
the the the the sexiest man of the year
hey who gives a [ __ ] they picked Blake
Shelton first of all I'll tell you one
thing I think Blake Shelton is one of
the most sexy [ __ ] in the world
that dude is [ __ ] awesome that dudes
first of all he's tall as [ __ ] he's got
a nice face cool hair yeah he's got
those Barbara barbar tattoo has very
awful but he knows it I feel like okay
he dresses in flannel he's cool and
here's the sexiest thing about him he's
[ __ ] relaxed he [ __ ] dude how much
confidence does that guy have I think if
you could like pick the most confident
guy in the world it would be him cuz he
just doesn't give a [ __ ] he just shows
up he's like what you want me to do it's
so funny to me i watch that guy and i
think like when he shows up he's just
like yeah where's the camera where you
want me to do all right let's do it he
just sits down he's like sure yeah let's
do it
and he just does it and then he [ __ ]
gets up and leaves and he's like cool
I'm gonna go about my day I'll catch you
guys later what are we shooting shooting
a promo for iHeartRadio cool let's do
this ha ha and then you say something
he's like alright and then he just is
like so respectful you guys sexy
it just drives me nuts how people will
get on the thing and be like picture the
people that saw Jason Momoa standing
waist-deep in a lake and then thought
Blake Shelton was the sexiest man in the
world yeah Jason Momoa sexy [ __ ] but
they got to pick someone who gives a
[ __ ]
also Blake Shelton is so famous they
gotta pick the one of the most famous
guys ever you know Jason Momoa is real
famous he's Aquaman but he's not Blake
Shelton famous dude Blake Shelton can go
to [ __ ] tribes in Africa and they'd
be like look he's from TV you know also
Jason Momoa take that hat off your head
yeah man he's cool dude he's a cool dude
but also wears some now he's mainly [ __ ]
though I do like him but yeah dude
people were just like oh did everybody
die is that why they picked Blake
Shelton
dude who's getting mad at the [ __ ]
People magazine that shit's always been
awful anyway who'd they pick last year
would they pick [ __ ] all the other
years when you they pick Matthew
McConaughey McConaughey okay to pick
Brad Pitt okay they pick [ __ ] Udrih
sell but maybe one year that's a sexy
[ __ ] though dude [ __ ] he drew
salba this is uh cool as [ __ ] and I was
he's got a good accent too like that
dude is British how much does Aegis Elba
do so much Molly
you know I feel like Eaters Elba
probably does so much Molly I feel like
he's just like Oh like we're every shows
up he's just like we got you got a Fonda
hookups like to his people to his
handlers I'll be like up is mo Lee in my
room we got Fonda hookups
he'll show up to like he'll do like a
conference in Australia about like some
new movies doing about the Dark Tower
and eat as soon as he lands he's like
what floor do you have the UM the
hookups it'll be like what do you mean I
need to get going here I'm not gonna do
this [ __ ] press junkets without doing
the [ __ ] male I need to rub him in
mouth one time I was talking to a girl
and she said she went to Coachella and
she had never done Molly and she was
like had her arms up and she was dancing
around in the Coachella [ __ ] and
somebody came up behind her and wiped
[ __ ] Molly on her face dude hey let
me taste some okay
if somebody ever did that to me now I've
never done Molly I've never done drugs
if somebody ever [ __ ] snuck some
drugs into me I'll tell you right now I
would fight everyone around me until I
was either dead or high that's how it
will go if you wiped Molly in my mouth
everybody around that person who did
that is complicit I'm fighting everybody
I see until I'm dead or tripping cuz I
know on some trip and I'm not gonna want
to fight everybody right I'll be like I
would that'll be hilarious to be like
fighting and Shinji's yeah and just if
you were winning just [ __ ] beating
the [ __ ] out everybody haha just high
kicks and [ __ ] plan and just pop a
hot choking people out and doing arm
bars yeah and then more [ __ ] people
coming come on and then all of a sudden
you're just like [ __ ] em hmm ah [ __ ] ah
[ __ ] man
is so [ __ ] good the [ __ ] Papa and
then you're fighting and then you're
wrestling but then also it kind of feels
good because people are like grabbing on
you and [ __ ] and you're like oh god damn
it until all of a sudden it just turns
into [ __ ] one more time got me
feeling so free
they got me Santa brain celebrate and
dance with me and you're still fighting
a little bit you're like Popeye but
you're like one more time and you're
just sweating so whoo
yeah XANA brain huh but if he and I oh
yeah just like oh [ __ ] [ __ ] I've said I
prayed Papa come on time somebody's on
your back and you're just like [ __ ]
you hike them up on your shoulders and
you're like well on time got me feeling
so free but you got somebody on your
shoulders and you're having a good time
but also you're still kind of fighting
people and then all of a sudden you just
let loose and you're just like you know
what [ __ ] oh yeah come on celebrate
with me and then the beat drops yeah and
your [ __ ] bloody and exhausting your
shirts rip and you're just like [ __ ]
this place rocks and you just have a
blast for [ __ ] seven hours until all
your spinal fluid is gone that would be
that would be me that would be what I
did and then once I came to and all the
[ __ ] all the guys who were complicit
came to we'd be like dude that [ __ ]
rocked that was one for the ages but if
any of you are ever complicit in putting
Molly in my face again we're doing it
all over again and then look at me and
they go like this oh yeah we are dude
and then we [ __ ] ride off into the
sunset
sanim bay and then so free and on a set
up bang do them in and then of me and
the credits just roll as people roll off
into the sunset and it's me and the guy
from he to mama tambien like that was
like he was there dude [ __ ] this is
what it see this is what I'm talking
about when I talk about the [ __ ] I
don't need I don't want to go do [ __ ] I
don't want to go when people are like
let's go [ __ ] and check it out when
Moreno Ohio or whatever the [ __ ] we are
my openers like we go just go see a
[ __ ] Rockies game whoa dude I don't
want to watch guys play baseball when I
can just think of [ __ ] like that
that's so [ __ ] art to me to think of
a guy getting [ __ ] molly'd in his
face
fighting until he got high and then
riding off into the sunset bro what the
[ __ ] I'm gonna go watch the Rockies play
the [ __ ] out of here dude
we've got imaginations man and I'm gonna
watch a Hawaii or whatever the [ __ ] that
thing is we've got imaginations and you
want me to watch return to me with David
Duchovny [ __ ] let my whole [ __ ] if
you don't like me you could play it fast
forward you could press fast forward
Crick's don't like me lick my whole
[ __ ] was that good
insecure jay-z critics don't like me I
lick my whole [ __ ]
was that good let's put it on and let's
put it on in the my in the song ho ho
why you think they call me didn't why
you think they call me ho cuz you asked
us to okay yo chill chill chill they do
that that's my favorite every rapper is
like yo why you think they call me
[ __ ] this because you [ __ ] asked
people to be like if I was like yo why
do you think they call my [ __ ]
podcast listeners babies because I
[ __ ] called them babies hey [ __ ] is
wrong with you oh yeah I'm Santa brain
what is that song that's that [ __ ]
you know what song is like the number
one song like that that style of song is
that [ __ ] [ __ ] the Bedingfield one
two two two two ding ding wait what can
I could do this that whole [ __ ] got
to get through this like gotta get will
guide you through what do it not only
these Vegas [ __ ] dance songs do dance
songs are so vague like Dan not Dan the
the what do you call him [ __ ] what do
you call that genre muse
anything you'd hear in a club what ya
house or whatever the [ __ ] that's like a
90s turn but like what they call it
EDM now I guess India so old closing in
on 40 but the [ __ ] gym ding-ding-ding
Jim Jim Jim there's nothing there's not
a more 2003 song that ever came out then
that [ __ ] Daniel Bedingfield song
Daniel Bedingfield is a name and he's
not a lowered you know dude all those
[ __ ] the EDM songs are the dance
songs of the trance songs were them
whatever rhymes with [ __ ] SHM ants is
like [ __ ] and of course Daniel
Bedingfield looks like that we just
googled him and of course he looks like
that of course he looks like the bad guy
of course it looks like a bad guy in a
movie where there's too much Brown and
green in it of course then your bed and
field it looks like a guy that when you
grew up never listened to his parents
and now says he loves his parents so
much
of course the any better film looks like
a guy who fought people when he was in
high school and then went to college and
definitely picked up something like
philosophical studies and now does drugs
recreationally and talks about him a lot
as they help [ __ ] people and their
psychology of course this really looks
like so so anyway every every dance
every dance song every dance or [ __ ]
Club the song and the club song they
play is so [ __ ] vague I'm gonna get
through this we gotta get there on the
spot man now I'm gonna get through
understand let them dance the only
student you get through what dude what
what the crowd heartache the [ __ ] every
song every day a [ __ ] song like that
is like [ __ ] trying like an angle high
up high
[Music]
dan 10 you know we got to get through
what [ __ ] in a room full of marshmallows
that's what that song is about to me you
gotta get thrown ass some ching ching
ching ching ching ching ching ting ting
got a little Sun of marshmallows you
gotta get this ting ting ting
give me a machete and I'll just eat a
lot I'll just eat through it you gotta
get the Lance
ching ching ching ching ching ching I
look like a guy who got not to find some
hands gone and now I look like a guy who
knows my parents and talks about it so
much ching ching in a cool mate - ching
ching ching ching ching ching gotta get
thrown a ass
I gotta get doing this conversation
where I'll talk about how I let my pair
as much shooting in a cool way
ching ching ching not in the doorway in
an ironic way like i know i'm dorky but
it's cool because I'm owning it and so
I'm sexy a ching ching ching ching Daft
Punk Santa by hey oh yeah Daft Punk and
a more British word than daft
what was that song that goes I'm Luo man
Lee my so my buddy when I was younger
thought it was I'm blue if I were green
I would die he thought it was I'm blue
if I ever agree you know I would die I'm
like yeah man no it's not just use your
ears ears ears use Google if I were
green I would die imagine the song was
if I'm blue if I was green I would die
da ba dee you know David II was in the
song title dude how about the guy who
[ __ ] made the song the news this new
song that came out take a knee my ass
did you see
one fire he didn't see it but it's a
country singer of course and he was like
taking me my ass and then google it take
a knee my ass and then in the quotes is
like misspelled me nee spelled at any e1
fire take a knee my ass too many body
parts in the song take a knee my ass
what a [ __ ] look this is not
political believe what you want to about
protesting or not protesting but that is
the look at that guy's [ __ ] face you
know that guy's racist just look at them
look at them the more racist you are you
know what the more the Bill of your hat
points up the more racist you are his
key got one of those cowboy hats that
swoops up it looks like you could
[ __ ] Tony Hawk on it
that's why cowboy that's why [ __ ]
Cowboys are the most racist you know
Cowboys are so racist that they don't
even know they don't even know they're
being racist you know what I mean
they'll be like well you know it's cuz
he's got [ __ ] darker skin than us and
you're like whoa whoa whoa whoa we were
talking about poker him that's why I bet
Saul RG doesn't know the game cuz of the
shade of his skin
oh whoa dude hey no it's it's not
alright alright now yeah can you I don't
think Kenya you can turkey the play
I pledge allegiance to the flag ah what
the United States of America [ __ ] all
the black people that's what it's doing
right now I'll stand and place my hand
upon my heart every time her anthem
plays and stare directly at a black man
and make him known TV take their stand
on bended knee whether its own ass
returned for granted I mean those whose
freedom was not free I say take a name
my ass Oh weird oh this is weird out Oh
weird now made this alright stop it
Oh Weird Al wrote this song so that's
cool I was cool that we oh I told the
producer to stop it and it stopped and
started again so one fine dude
I mean take what this good old boy
[ __ ] you know whether it's on a
astroturf here's the deal how about this
man the word astroturf should never be
in a song just just don't put the word
astroturf in a song take a knee my ass
too many body parts in the title take a
knee my ass oh god you know that guy's
gonna have the most best Thanksgiving
you know come on over you know that
guy's just gonna have the best
Thanksgiving with his [ __ ] scooping
up ass hat and he's gonna put the
guacamole in it and just place the hat
down and put the chips in the center and
be like this is what these hats are good
for a good old American it's not even
American it's Mexican get all American
guacamole that's right you know we're
gonna watch the Lions play today ain't
that right they play
every Thanksgiving and if anybody gets
too low to the ground I'm gonna shoot
him I'll shoot him in the [ __ ] face
cuz I I know ain't nobody taking a knee
if somebody takes a knee my ass eyes
chin shoulders can't stop saying body
parts take a knee my ass [ __ ] [ __ ] that
stupid song [ __ ] that stupid song not
politically it's just a bad song and
also Weird Al wrote it so that's cool
that's gonna have the best Thanksgiving
so yeah all right let's do these
movement look you have heard me talk
about movin and I'm sure you got
yourself a watch now let's finish your
holiday shopping and go to movement and
get a watch for someone on your list
it'll be it's very cool gift movement
watches started just 95 dollars at a
department store you're gonna pay 400 to
500 dollars movement figured out by
selling online they were able to cut the
middleman so they're able to do that
you know retail markup you know it give
you the best possible price em VMT
watches make a wonderful holiday gives
to I'm saying it I'm spelling it cuz
it's how it's spelled over 1 million
watches sold in over 160 countries my
watch is cool it's gold and when I wear
it I get lots of compliments and it's
very cool and it makes me look like I
know what I'm doing even though I don't
but movement does they help you out get
50% off today with free shipping and
free returns by going to MVM t.com /
Congrats clean design and a great
fashion statement go to MVM t-dot-com /
Congrats join the movement texture
whether you're looking for a dependable
political reporting high quality
storytelling or the latest on culture
and entertainment magazines deliver it
with high-quality writing and beautiful
photography and I can get all your
magazines in one place with texture
texture app gives you unlimited access
to over 200 premium magazines texture
has lead
titles like time you ever heard of it
the Atlantic you ever heard of it
The New Yorker Vanity Fair and wired you
ever heard of those or do you live under
rock
and right now you can try texture for
free I do it
I like the magazine's I listen to them
all catalogued I've been using it on my
iPad so imagine having your favorite
magazines and their back issues anytime
anywhere start your free texture trial
go to texture dot-com / Congrats
if you choose to continue podcast
listeners will get texture for just
$9.99 a month that's over 30% of their
listed price there are also great gift
options available for the holiday season
go to texture calm / congrats to start
your free trial today
that's textured calm / congrats textured
calm / congrats set it to much yeah
taking me my you know what yeah it's
weird man there's the whole [ __ ] I
feel like I feel like this whole stuff
that everything becomes an issue like
this whole like levar ball thing like
that Trump's tweeting about I feel like
he's doing it directly to [ __ ] not
like by the way here's something that
got overshadowed because of that the
[ __ ] who's the guy the that was on
like Trump's chair that like was all
against the LGBT and he literally pled
guilty yesterday to [ __ ] for child
sex trafficking did you know that yeah
like so I feel like Trump's like oh
that's happening in my [ __ ] [ __ ] okay
hey levar ball [ __ ] you like dude who
gives a [ __ ] what levar ball says about
you who gives a [ __ ] what anyone with
the last name ball says if I my last
name was ball I would change it for
shirt I would make it like Thompson
you know ball big baller brand the balls
the [ __ ] balls Italian when you say
when you see the whole family a the
balls the [ __ ] balls huh are the kids
the kids in that family are all in the
[ __ ] awkward stage like when are they
getting out of that they all look like
teenagers I know probably one of them
but they all look geeky as [ __ ] you know
look at him
they're so teenage all of them look at
the one in the middle it was so teenage
he looks like what's his Sideshow Bob oh
man
the dad you know so proud
yeah [ __ ] we getting it in
that's what his face always looks like
any picture you ever see of levar ball
it looks like he's thinking
yeah [ __ ] we getting it in look
Google any picture of levar ball
yeah [ __ ] we getting in in man
yeah [ __ ] we getting it in
everyone would we look that did
different levels of that he's got a
[ __ ] tie with BBB on it oh damn she's
taking yeah he's taking it to the bank
dude that guy's that guy's did [ __ ]
that guy's awesome dude
I don't know anything about that guy but
this guy [ __ ]
straight-up American [ __ ] dream
coming true
this guy outspoken made it a brand and
now yeah [ __ ] we getting it in
guys killing it I [ __ ] like guys like
that man I know nothing about him but he
created a brand and now it's a brand
that's what [ __ ] that's how you
backup the [ __ ] Brinks truck
dude that's how [ __ ] that's honestly
I mean that's how guys who make brands
are incredible guys who are able to
[ __ ] make what they do in their life
a brand are incredible to me like even
Trump how [ __ ] did this guy do that I
mean they sell this by the way Trump
sells merch you know Trump sells merge
like Trump hatched from shirts didn't
they make [ __ ] one president get rid
of his peanut farm
well what happened to that yes that's
out the window
they made Jimmy Carter get rid of his
peanut farm Trump sells hats you know
Trump sells polo shirts and they made
Jimmy Carter get rid of his peanut farm
good All American trying to get shunting
ttan ttan noses dried and [ __ ] um hey
how come dude you guys watch oh I've
never talked about this and I watch the
show and I always wanted to talk about
on the podcast do you guys watch the
narcos do you while you laughing dude
narcos okay look first of all the guy
who plays [ __ ] Pablo Escobar on
narcos I'm telling you right now that's
the best acting I've seen in years dude
he's Pablo Escobar and I don't even mean
he's the real Pablo Escobar I mean he
created a [ __ ] character even though
there's a real Pablo Escobar
he made this guy on TV Pablo Escobar
maybe he's not like the real Pablo
Escobar doesn't matter that guy in his
head is literally thinking I'm not the
actor I'm this guy but then he forgets
that and just as that guy that acting
that that guy does as Pablo Escobar has
not been seen since like early Robert De
Niro [ __ ] I mean he's so good dude he is
so fun
and good and there is and I love that I
love the show it takes a little bit
getting into because the [ __ ]
voice-over dude they use the voice-over
they they have the guy the white guy
whatever the [ __ ] that guy is who played
the bad guy in the the Logan movie
whatever his name is
who the voiceover everybody's good but
the voiceover like all this guy talks
about is hey we were like every it's the
most unnecessary voiceover that's the
thing I don't get about that show is it
could just be the show no there's a
thing in writing and in screenwriting
where they say like any you can make any
movie without the voice-over and it's
better if you don't but all the best
movies that you ever [ __ ] have
watched have voiceover on it so it's
kind of like it's kind of like a
[ __ ] thing like you they say in
screenwriting when you when you learn it
like you never need to have a voiceover
you can always like but voice all the
best movies have voiceovers on it I
can't even think of one right now
Goodfellas as far back as I can remember
I always wanted to be a gangster and
then beanie sigel put it on his album
and he started it could do rappers love
[ __ ] Italian gangster [ __ ] man
you see too many movies that's why Tupac
said that but no when [ __ ] beanie
sigel came out with an album he took us
to he like took a page from the good
Phyllis's and he says as far as back as
I could remember I always wanted to be a
gangster as far as back he says hey
Saddam as far back as I remember I could
always want it to be a gangster but um
Boyd what's his name Boyd is that the
guy Oh Donald Pierce oh no no that's him
yeah that's the narcos guy right so he's
good I'm not saying he's not good but
he's good in the [ __ ] show he's great
but I like the guy he's awesome the
voice-over dude is hilarious though it's
unnecessary and it's said describing
it's like it's like what narcos didn't
know was we were two steps ahead of them
well what the narcos didn't know was we
were we were always two steps ahead of
him
but then what we didn't realize was that
the narcos were four steps behind us so
we had to go six steps back now in Miami
two steps were way different than what
it was down in Colombia no we were we
were used to two steps in Miami but two
steps in Colombia was technically one
and a half steps due to the elevation
and drug trafficking we had to do math
and make sure that every one and a half
steps we took was actually two steps
this is the way we got ahead of the
narcos and you're just like uh okay it's
just showing [ __ ] scrolling shots of
like cocoa leaves Pablo Escobar didn't
realize as we had him right where we
wanted but what we didn't realize was
that Pablo had us right where he wanted
before that so what we had to do was
jockey around and move positions without
letting them know but also we had to
keep him right where we wanted and that
was how we got the jump on narcos but we
got to jump on them but what we didn't
realize was that they were underwater
and you can't jump in water so what we
had to do was you guessed it drain the
narcos pool and you're just like uh okay
and then they [ __ ] stabbed somebody
in the face and you're like I was good
you see we didn't realize that the
narcos had private jets and they were
taking the all the all the coke from one
area to another so when we got to the
area they were already somewhere else
and even though we had him right where
we wanted we realized one thing where we
wanted wasn't actually where we needed
uh then they [ __ ] stabbed somebody in
the [ __ ] and make him eat it you see the
narcos were funny not funny like haha
but the kind of funny where you just sit
back and you look and think damn that's
funny
so taking two steps every one and a half
steps and the elevation taken into
account because Columbia was a lot lower
than Miami we were used to three feet
above sea level but where the narcos
were were ten feet below sea level so
what we had to do was get taller guys oh
you see when the narcos came it changed
everything everything from buying
selling the government killing winning
baseball shirts running aliens sky and
all those things were two steps ahead of
us and then somebody gets [ __ ] shot
in the [ __ ] eye you see what the
narcos didn't know was that's every
[ __ ] in the beginning of every
monologue and the voice-over you see
what we didn't know you see what the
narcos didn't know was you see what paul
didn't remember you see what my wife
didn't realize was you see what the
one-year-old baby we just adopted from
the narcos didn't know was googoo gaga
[Laughter]
now the baby said googoo gaga we didn't
know what he meant but what we didn't
realize was the narcos knew exactly what
baby talk was so we got an informant we
got someone who could understand baby
talk and his name was poison we got
poison talking to that baby baby would
say googoo gaga to poison and poison
would ship 20 kilos back to Miami that's
how the operation was we had him right
where we wanted and then they [ __ ]
stretch someone's limb so hard that
their shoulders come out of their
sockets
the voiceover in narcos dude [ __ ] we all
had sneakers on I feel like that in the
middle of that show there could be a
voiceover where the guy just for no
reason said we all had sneakers on
during this scene and you just would
literally not even realize it and you'd
be and then they'd [ __ ] somebody
would like [ __ ] like rape someone and
then stab them in the head and then
you'd be like wow this just [ __ ]
gritty you notice the narcos wearing
sneakers
we all had sneakers oh no get away from
me No
it shows gritty that guy is blue eyes
[ __ ] more ads time to back up this
[ __ ] Brinks truck [ __ ] blue
apron blue apron is the number one fresh
ingredient and recipe delivery service
in the country do you know that you do
now it's it's awesome okay look blue a
brewery not blue apron because it's not
blue a friend it's blue apron with a P
it offers three plans to person meal
plan it's great if you have someone if
you're not lonely meals that serve two
people choose from eight new recipes per
week with the choice to receive either
two or three recipes any week it's too
many numbers however it makes sense
family meal plan meals that serve four
people choose from four new recipes per
week with the choice to receive either
two three or four recipes any week wine
wine plan six bottles of wine renowned
wine makers deliver monthly you see what
the narcos didn't know was they've got
two or three recipes any week but you
could get meals that serve four people
choose for new recipes per week with the
choice to receive either two three or
four recipes any week now if you got the
two-person meal plan choose from eight
new recipes ten eleven forty seven and
we're all wearing sneakers upcoming
meals include hey they're definitely for
they're definitely
and the ad from us after this seared
steaks and garlic butter with oven fries
and romaine salad now that sounds
amazing butternut squash pasta with kale
and brown butter walnuts barramundi I
ate that in Australia it's real good and
mixed mushrooms with jasmine rice and
napa cabbage roasted chicken and fall
vegetables nothing's better than fall
vegetables dude when you describe
vegetables from a season forget it dude
fall vegetables are so good they really
are you ever taste fall blue apron you
haven't tasteful go outside and just
open your mouth near some Brown fallen
leaves there you go ginger compote and
cranberry come on
dude what are you doing putting
restaurant stuff in your mouth check out
this week's menu and get $30 off your
first order with free shipping by going
to blue apron dot-com slash Congrats
you will love how good it feels in taste
to create incredible home-cooked meals
with blue aprons so don't wait the
that's blue apron dot-com / Congrats
blue apron a better way to cook
customize it baby square cash you know
what the babies are all switching your
baby switch cash up is the number one
finance app in the App Store
so go it's because it's the best way to
pay people back friends family
co-workers narcos anyone spending and
receiving sending and receiving money is
totally free and it's fast most payments
can be deposited directly into your bank
account in seconds download the square
cash app link it to your debit or credit
card
select an amount to send and type in a
friend's phone number or email address
to a clip complete the payment to get a
notification they receive money that's
it no good square cash is better than
the other guys it's not a social network
I used it the other day and nobody knew
I was paying for what I was paying for
it's shady but it's true cash card it's
a new black debit card you can design
yourself design it yourself via they get
the app the cash
card allows you to use the cash at the
cash that you keep in the app anywhere
you want you get notifications and you
can laser at your car to personalise it
and it will be delivered directly to you
for free they come to your door knock on
it and you got a black cash card the
cash app team is constantly building
awesome new féin features so what are
you doing you wanna go see new features
get it
download the free cash app for iOS or
Android now no Elder this week cool it's
all good sometimes we have one sometimes
we don't see what the elders didn't know
was sometimes we pick them every week
but sometimes we don't we can go buy
sometimes two sometimes we'll name four
elders in one week like we did with the
true babies but what narcos didn't know
was it was up to us papaya we takin over
City and it um looking for the most
[ __ ] up Instagram post of the week
brown sometimes I think about how it was
married that's crazy dude I was married
tenure no I guess it's like 12 years ago
now what the narcos didn't know was I
was married before and I think honestly
everyone should go through that and I
don't you know maybe that self-centered
or egotistical but going through a
marriage when you're young and realizing
what it is talk about [ __ ] big baller
brand dude yeah we gettin it in
[ __ ] when you get married and
divorced after two years when you're 25
yeah we get needy and [ __ ] you
know what life's about you know what
relationships are about you know you've
been through you've been a throw
everything you've been through the
relationship you've been through you've
been through fucking's you've been
through relationships you've been
through marriage you've been through
everything and you know what the [ __ ] it
is man you know what it's like so
when you really get married you know
what's up you know what's up dude you
get that princess [ __ ] out the way and
then you get the real [ __ ] [ __ ] going
on I know it sounds a little defensive
and a little you know but I'm telling
you man if you're going through a
divorce right now and you're young that
[ __ ] is [ __ ] you know what you're
going through some real good candy [ __ ]
cuz you need it dude now [ __ ] candy
you're eating if some like mmm you know
protein and some [ __ ] and some macro you
need to [ __ ] grow and develop that's
how it is because then you know what
it's all about then you're not being a
[ __ ] idiot and getting married when
you're like 30 and thinking yeah this is
what it is you don't know what it is and
then you get divorced when you're 35 and
she taken owe you [ __ ]
she taken oh your mom you don't want her
to take all your money you want to be
fair you want to give her some money if
she helped you out but you don't want
her to take all your money and take you
to the [ __ ] Bank
um you wanted to take all your [ __ ]
Olivia Munn you don't want her to take
all your [ __ ] Olivia Munn sure if she
deserves some Olivia Munn you give her
some Olivia Munn
but dude come on man you want to be this
guy yeah we getting it in [ __ ]
you trying to be loved our ball with
three kids if his wife left him now he
wouldn't be BBB he'd be B and a half
dude he'd be like yeah we kind of still
getting it in a little bit but you know
how things go it's hard [ __ ]
that's what he'd be doing instead he's
got that [ __ ] [ __ ] eating grin yeah
we getting it in you know what rhymes
with [ __ ] eating grin
yeah we getting it in [ __ ]
so cuz marriage is real bro once you get
the government involved in your
relationship
Oh Oh once you get a [ __ ] piece of
paper signed and you gotta sign it and
she's got to sign it because you get
married and you get the government
involved you got to go to a courthouse
uh-oh she doin hey dude
marriage is a scam but guess what we're
still gonna do it you know why you fall
in love that's what it is man love [ __ ]
you up
it really does [ __ ] you up and people
are like but it's great but it's
beautiful but I don't know what my life
will be without her I don't know what my
life will be without him I don't know
what we would do without our beautiful
kids you know what you'd be doing
[ __ ] and sucking and spending money
that's what you'd be doing you'd have a
great life lonely sure sometimes but a
lot of times you'd forget your
loneliness and you'd be [ __ ] sucking
and getting it in [ __ ] you know
you'd be doing going to the movies if
you want you know what else you'd be
doing [ __ ] and sucking and jerking if
you want that's what you'd be doing
sounds like a great life you can just go
on a walk and look at some [ __ ]
coyotes if you want if you got kids and
you're married you can't do that dude
there you got a [ __ ] designate time
for it all I'm saying man one time I had
a conversation with an older man at
Greenblatt's and he just started talking
to me man and of course just like all
older guys that start talking here in
diners he had on tinted sunglasses on
tinted glasses are not sunglasses but
tinted glasses and he talked to me man
in here I got [ __ ] beautiful a little
bit longer grayish hair that looked like
you know he looked a little bit like a
Jerry Speaker Jerry Springer if he went
on a [ __ ] bender but he had like a
glow to him and a caller you got a
collar on and his skin looked good old
but good he didn't have anything that
said hey I'm not an old guy he had an an
air that was like I'm an old guy and I'm
owned in it and he was eating alone at
Greenblatt's and he started talking to
me and my friend and I don't remember
who I was with because that person
wasn't important what was important was
me and this guy
and I was going through some [ __ ] with a
girl and I don't know if you like sensed
it or some [ __ ] I don't know if this guy
really existed but like he started
talking to me and and he was like hey
you married and I was like I was married
and he was like ah cool I said what
about you he said never been married
this guy was in his 60s at least well no
he's in the 60s for sure and I was like
no never and he was like nah never had a
few relationships but you know I never
was never was married never really had a
long thing going on now in my head I'm
thinking all guys self as [ __ ] must be
crazy I mean if you're not married by
the time you're 60 or if you never had
like a ten-year relationship by the time
you're 60 I don't know man I mean it's
probably got a lot probs you know but
this guy with his tinted suk with his
tinted glasses not sunglasses and his
long [ __ ] jerry springer hair who
look like Jerry Springer needed a
haircut but he had a glow to him I told
you he said I said do you ever regret
never getting married or having kids or
anything like that and he he looked at
me and he said no not for a second and I
know guys who would say that as 60
something years old and I know that they
would say that and I know I wouldn't
believe that but for some reason I
believed this [ __ ]
he was laughing we were talking he was
laughing it wasn't fooling me with the
laughs and yeah maybe he had some
[ __ ] demons or some darkness in him
maybe but also he was laughing genuine
laughs so what the [ __ ] does it matter
what you do so basically you got to do
what you want man and if marrying a girl
is what you want and being with a guy is
what you want then do that but don't
[ __ ] do it when you're 30 just
because that's what happens you know if
you're young and you [ __ ] up and you
got involved and you did it and you got
out and now you know what life and
marriage is all about [ __ ] block up
block up you know but if you're just
[ __ ] doing it because that's the
natural progression is [ __ ] you don't
want to get the [ __ ] out of that
lationship
cuz there's that guy and you could be
that guy but you could also be levar
ball with three kids and a [ __ ] wife
yeah [ __ ] we gettin it in but
the secret is you could be getting it in
by just being [ __ ] solo and rolling
on your dole oh dude what is rolling on
your dole oh I don't know I never knew
what it was but you can do that roll on
your [ __ ] dole oh you think [ __ ]
Daniel Bedingfield isn't rolling on his
dole oh he is probably and even if he's
not the idea of Daniel Bedingfield is
rolling on his dole oh it's like in
space balls or [ __ ] no it's like in
space balls star wars when he loses the
[ __ ] it's always inside him what's
that movie where he's like oh you lost
its space pause where you lose the ring
and you're like not it's always inside
you or some [ __ ] it's not the ring
whatever [ __ ] movie that is it's not
the ring it's what since it's inside you
it's not the ring that's doing it
something it's not a ring but it's in
space balls
it's [ __ ] inside you dude I don't
know you know
see that's why this is a cult dude I'm
trying to help you [ __ ] I'm
trying to get out to that log cabin with
the surrounding log cabins that are not
as good as the one log cabin and I get
that one because I'm the leader and
we're all growing our [ __ ] hair out
because we're all trying to look like
Jerry Springer after he needs a haircut
and our [ __ ] mantra is that when we
sit around that [ __ ] in that circle
we breathe in and then we breathe out
and we say very quietly yeah
[ __ ] we get it and then we go
out and have some activities you know
thanks for being a part of my cult try
to recruit people by showing them the
podcast on this podcast is one episode
they'll understand if they don't then
they don't get it
Colts are cool because not everybody is
in them dude we don't it's not everybody
that's in this cult this is us that's in
this [ __ ] this is us that's in
the you think I'm not exhibiting cult
behavior yeah do you [ __ ] mind dude
Charles Manson just died dude I don't
want anyone to die but you know I'm
saying it's like well I mean he was a
piece of [ __ ] I meant the people that he
anyway
I'm trying to look at this [ __ ] most
[ __ ] up Instagram post of the week and
maybe I'll get there and I won't want to
do it maybe I'll get to the page where I
saw most [ __ ] up in certain poses week
maybe I won't want to do it and you know
what that's okay because what I want
these [ __ ] idiots on Instagram look
at these [ __ ] look at this they
already did that one um uh yeah maybe I
won't do it maybe I won't do it up up
never mind didn't want to do one for a
sec but gotta do it here hey guys it's
time for the most [ __ ] up Instagram
post of the week well this is one I
wasn't gonna do it but wow I mean this
is amazing dude this is most [ __ ] up
Instagram post of the week
foreign Edition we've done one before
but these are always my favorite because
this guy writes it in English but it's
from Switzerland and obviously does not
speak English that well now this is
awesome because it has all the things
the most [ __ ] up Instagram posts of
the week's always have but on top of
that it has errors and it's way too
foreign okay here we go
god this is just one of the best ones I
think period okay it has an ex like you
know this is the caption for then I'm
gonna tell you what the [ __ ] picture
is it has an ex like the emoji and then
it says value yourself and then it has a
bunch of lines under it and then it says
under that this is the caption a bunch
of lines under it like the little short
lines that they do it it separate the
[ __ ] even though they don't need to
because it's it's Instagram and he says
every day you are telling yourself that
you are great will bring you to a more
self-confident person every day you are
smiling for yourself will change your
inner believes and also inner believes
by the way and also the people hanging
around you your environment period not a
sentence people will recognize with an S
this aura and make them at the same time
feel good too
sure okay that makes sense a little bit
this guy is asked to Swiss he's standing
outside of his car with an open door and
he's in a field the car is on in a field
now nothing is more Swiss
and Switzerland like nothing is more
Zurich than having a car on grass with a
blonde guy in a hoodie standing like
he's getting into it with a door coming
out and dude this is the most swiss part
there is writing on the photo like he
put it through an app and it says all
about smiling that's more Swiss than
Swiss cheese that's more Swiss than
valve's that's more Swiss then Phelps do
you want to climb Phelps or do you want
to [ __ ] put a picture on Instagram
and write over it all about smiling Oh
booth about put all about smiling on
there yeah
Wow that would be amazing Wow look at
that that's what they did with him and
his buddy who's definitely blond - he's
a blonde of course you guys are the [ __ ]
we're gonna wrap it up we're gonna take
one question from Keith Hal Burroughs
8th Lord Jesus Christ I mean how'd you
how did you not become a bad guy with
the name like that
my name is Keith halberd Zeidler Keith
is idler the I mean it's a bad guy why
do some guys put one hand on the wall
and lean at the urinal congratulations
part gaming the system you know what
that's [ __ ] weird dude to do that
actually
you got boner you're trying to angle it
you try an angle you [ __ ] you try name
hey do it take the hand off because
you're not that tired
just chill if you got bone or maybe
that's why but yeah guys but also don't
touch the wall in the bathroom what are
you trying to get [ __ ] Hep C trying
to get Hep C you got it congratulations
you got it hey guys I have a nap right
now download the app
you got to download the app okay it's
crystally I show behind-the-scenes
footage from the cut podcast I show all
sorts of [ __ ] you get to see little
clips of of one fire and that's how it
is
so do that remember blue apron check out
this week's menu and get $30 off your
first order with free shipping by going
to blue apron calm / Congrats movement
get 15% off today with free shipping and
free returns by going to MDM t.com /
Congrats square cash have you switched
yet download the free square cash app
design your cash card get it for iOS or
Android now now guys this is a cult help
me out subscribe to the YouTube channel
it shows video of this podcast and for a
lot of the stuff I feel like it's better
to see me do it but I don't give a [ __ ]
if you want to listen to a listen to it
download my app as I said go get some
merch we got crazy cool merch and that's
a good thing for gift given the holiday
season's coming up show people their
[ __ ] Kudus show them the knock kudus
show them the [ __ ] true babies we got
shirts and sweatshirts of all shits
going on you get my [ __ ] silhouette
on it
silhouette subscribe rate and review the
show tweet me by using the handle at
congrats pod video episodes go up on
Tuesdays or Wednesdays we keep it lakhs
because we don't know when it's gonna
get done with they had an editing we
don't know how many visuals were gonna
add upcoming shows buy tickets at Chris
D'Elia calm
Irvine almost sold out just added
another show on Sunday San Jose San
Diego new show added Riverside on New
Year's Eve come [ __ ] drink some
shrimp egg man with you [ __ ]
Winnipeg added his second show Calgary
Canada man on fire incorrigible white
male black comic these are all Mike
specials watch Andrew watch it like it I
got a new I'm doing a guest spot a few
recurring spots on the show called alone
together which is on free form which I
think it's actually gonna be a really
funny show man
with Benji and Esther
Bengie nets are funny on this show and
thank you for listening have a good one
my babies see it the log cabin don't
forget to roll on your jello
[ __ ]
[Music]